As a CEO,
as a guy who's running this thing,
what,
what is this been his experience has been like for you?
Because I got to imagine that it wasn't anything that you predicted.
No one predicted Twitter,
right?
Yeah.
So to all of a sudden have this responsibility or change it everything.
And you're a young guy,
how old are you?
42 that's young to be in control of that much.
Like what?
And to have it over the time of,
but has it been 11 years or 10 years old?
They're 13 and March hill.
Yeah.
So you were really fucking young.
Yup.
Like what is that been like for you?
It's been a,
it's been both beautiful and scary and uncomfortable and learning and it's just
been a ton of learning and evolving and like,
uh,
it shows me every single day where I need to push myself and what I don't know.
And uh,
and I,
I think a big part is like just the realization that we're not going to be able
to do this alone.
And I don't think we have to either.
The,
these are,
these are what the technologies continue to allow us.
We can,
if we have to have all the answers around enforcement or policy,
what not,
we're,
we're not going to serve the world.
We have aspirations to serve every single person on the planet and we have
aspirations to,
you know,
be the first consideration for the global public conversation.
And you know,
if,
if we're the bottleneck for all of this,
we're not going to reach those aspirations.
So it just thinking deeply about how we might distribute more of this work and
decentralize,
uh,
more of it and look at,
look at,
you know,
the platform itself and like what we need to change to reach that reality.
And I think we've got to look really deepened foundational.
It goes back to,
you know,
the,
your question on one 40,
one of the things that we saw was,
you know,
we,
we shifted to 280 characters and that,
you know,
this 140 characters is so sacred.
You know,
it,
it became this cultural thing and I was in love with it.
And so many people are in love with it.
But one of the things we noticed as we move to two 80 is that the fast majority
of tweets that are broadcast don't go above one 40 even with that limitation
raced.
But where they do go above a one 40 is in replies.
When people reply,
they tend to go over the hundred 40 character limit and even bump up into the
two to 80 limit.
And what it a lot,
what we've seen,
it allow us just more nuance in the conversation and allows people to give more
context and,
and uh,
and kind of just get their experience on the table a bit more.
Whereas one 40 did not allow that.
So we,
we have seen that increase the health of those conversations and the
discussions.
So it's stuff like that that we need to question and not hold.
So,
so sacred.
Is there any consideration to expanding it further?
Uh,
now,
right now we were,
how about a million characters?
I know,
well we don't have edit tweets now,
so we did.
That's good or bad.
Well if you can't edit 140 characters are going to be really pissed off if you
write a million characters in cad.
Those things.
And you know what I would like,
I would like edit the ability to edit.
Like if you make a typo or something like that,
but also the ability for people to see the original.
Yeah,
like edit but see the original like site we're looking at exactly that.
Oh really?
We're looking at exactly that.
The reason we don't have it in the first place,
places we were born on SMS,
we were born on text messaging.
When you send a tax,
you can't take it back.
Right.
So when you send a tweet it goes to the world instantaneously.
You can't take it back.
So when we have to exist anyway,
I mean no matter what,
if you send someone something,
even if you are on Instagram,
people are going to know the original.
Yeah,
they screenshot it and they,
you know,
they,
they do their thing.
But like you could build it such that,
you know,
maybe we introduce a five second to 32nd to lay in the sending and within that
window you can edit.
I'm going to need more time than that dude.
I fuck,
fuck something up.
I'd like someone else to tell me you misspelled that word.
Oh Shit.
Did I?
God dammit.
The issue is autocorrect gets,
yeah,
totally.
But the issue with going longer than that,
it takes that realtime nature on the conversational flow out of it.
Then we're delaying these tweets and like when you're watching UFC,
are you watching like warriors basketball?
A lot of,
a lot of the great Twitter is like,
just like in the moment it just like,
you know,
it's the roar of the crowd.
It's like,
you know,
looking across a,
at someone you're in this virtual stadium worth and just saying like,
oh my God,
that shot.
Can you believe it?
Isn't clarity more important because you're not going to spend on context.
It depends on the kind of have the ability to communicate quickly.
Yeah.
But you also have the ability to clarify.
That's it.
That's where we need to really pay attention.
Because
if you're,
if you're in the context of an NBA game,
you want to be fast and you just want to be at the moment and you just,
you don't,
you want to be Robert.
If you're in the context of considering what the president interested or making
a particular statement,
then you probably need some,
some more time and we can be dynamic though.